hi Fred I'm really happy that we're
doing this because it's coming at a
really good time congrats are in order
you all clinched a planned spot how you
feeling uh that's not something I ever
thought would be a celebration but uh
we're here you know just trying to
finish up
um last couple weeks put ourselves in
good positions so it's you know it's a
good thing to be able to at least fight
for a chance to make it so you got to
try to be positive about it so I know
that you are very much so like a
basketball purist so you had thoughts
about what the play-in tournament was
going to be originally
thought shifted at all how do you feel
about the plan now I mean I'm happy
there's a plan now because you know we
need it but uh again I think you know
the game is changing a little bit uh the
league is is changing things and
switching it up so just trying to keep
an open mind with it
um understanding that you know it's here
so you got to be able to adapt and
adjust
um I'm not saying that it would have
been my idea you know what I mean but
you know we're here and hopefully you
know gives us a chance to uh sneak into
the playoffs this year so separately
from you know you and your opinion on it
how do you feel like the plan has
affected the way players play at this
point in the season it's changed
everything I think just from a business
standpoint you know you you're adding
two extra slots nine and ten now who in
other Seasons maybe that Gap will be a
little bit different I think eight or
nine sometimes is a little uh was a race
down to the last week but like now you
got teams that's 11th in their
conference fighting for the 10th spot so
it's like it makes it more competitive
down the stretch um it makes everything
way more dramatic
by Design By Design you know what I mean
so you got to be able to just be aware
and keep an open mind to that I think
you know that's a big part of it is just
more drama you know hopefully more
viewers and people are watching I mean
every game for the last couple weeks for
most of the teams has been very uh big
in terms of the standing so I think it's
working from the NBA standpoint for sure
I'm sure they are very happy yeah yeah
but it's also one of those things you
love it if you're maybe not involved
people when you're involved it's kind of
like I don't know if I'm fine no doubt I
mean with last year we I think we made
it to like six or something the previous
years it was like you know we weren't in
it so you got a whole different
perspective but now this year being in
that spot
um definitely changes things but you
know like I said just trying to be
positive about it yes and you also just
um established a franchise record for
assists in a game with 20. it's a lot of
assists uh did the night feel special
before the game started or when did you
know uh no not really I mean we had a
tough loss in Philly
um coming in here to Charlotte that's
playing you know playing a team with all
the guys out so they're playing a lot of
their younger players development guys
so just trying to go out there and be
aggressive and get a win yeah um really
was all was on my mind and the number
just came so it was really just in the
Florida game and just trying to be
aggressive well I mean you know humble
brag for you but you now hold the
franchise record for assist in a game
and points in a game and you were asked
about that last night and you had a
quote you said the further I get away
from 54 meaning the points the more I
appreciate it what did you mean by that
um just because like just for example
yesterday was a 2020 and you know my
automatically my next thought is like do
it again you know what I mean so I'm
already focused on the next thing when I
scored 54 I was like I could have really
had 70. so the next game I try to go do
it again and I played terrible in
Brooklyn and then you know you right
back to to normal so um I think just
trying to focus on the next thing you
lose sight of the moment and then now
look back like man I really had you know
a 50-point game and um it's getting more
common now but you know it's still a
short list of people and um you know you
got to be appreciative of the moment why
do you think it is so much more common
now like there has been a crazy number
of 50 plus point games just this season
yeah I think the the players are getting
better I think the defense is getting
harder to play I think the rules are
favoring the offense for sure and the
players are just getting that much
better and the scores are going up so
naturally you just see a rising and
scoring and
um these guys with the three-point shot
now
um we've seen 70s you know become more
of a thing like it's going to keep going
up you know that we've got incredible
guys incredible scores and skill sets in
this league I think that's the big
reason why
older guy in this league
um no but I'm starting to feel that way
you know as as the games go on as the
years go on like
um seven is just like a kind of like a
middle point you know what I mean where
it's a solid start I still I'm always
going to feel young you know I live
young like I think of myself as a young
guy that's how I came in
um but just seeing so many of the young
guys coming in and for me all of the
other players that have traveled the
same roads that I have and being able to
have relationships with those guys
um whether it's just a brief moment
before after a game or
um DM you know just seeing how much
impact the influence of the next
generation of players that's watch that
watch me play and watch me make my way
into the league I think that's what
makes me feel old even though you know I
feel pretty young in the league so I
mean what you're 29 your franchise
Cornerstone you've won a ring at this
point in your career what are you
looking for
um more just more of everything
um just not being satisfied I think with
the only really itch I have right now is
to try to get another championship
that's really the main thing that drives
me every day and I'm just building
myself up to be uh Dependable point
guard that can win a championship and I
think that's really all I think about
because out of everything I've done that
is the highest or the high that you can
get it's a team award it's a franchise
Award organization award
um it takes the entire group it takes a
full year to achieve it and it's just
you know that's the top of the mountain
so just trying to find ways to get back
to that is really you know the only itch
I have everything else is going to come
with me just striving to be the best I
can be in letting everything forward is
you touch on it a little bit but
obviously there's been a lot of talk
over the past weeks about just ring
culture and how we define success in the
NBA
you winning a championship seeing how
hard it is seeing what it takes how did
that change how you view brain culture
and the weight that we put on having
championships yeah I think it's it's
like a double-edged sword for me because
I think
winning it made me understand why we put
so much emphasis on that because it is
such a hard thing to do but also
seeing exactly what took what it took to
get there
um allowed me to have greater
perspective on guys that hadn't won one
because when when you don't know you
just always just attributed to like oh
this guy wasn't good enough to win a
ring or but it's like it's so much more
than just one person it goes into
everything that the organization is
doing from ownership down to official
here or missed call here a sprained
ankle here a couple injuries in the
finals for us for Golden State like it
was just so much that went into that
year we traded our franchise player we
fired the coach of the year like it was
so much that went into winning that
championship for us that it changed the
way I looked at you know
some other superstars in this league
that get a bad rap for not winning a
ring because there's just so much that
goes into it I also think it's
interesting that not winning a ring
always falls on the players yeah
like uh it takes a lot of people but the
only people that were saying were not
worthy of this ring were the people on
the court yeah but what about everybody
that makes the decisions yeah I think
for me just I just sum it up like I'm
not really a debater like when it comes
to basketball like I'll talk amongst my
peers and you know the locker room and
things like that but like I think it
really only comes up in like debate
culture basketball you know it's used as
a point of reference for whatever
argument you're trying to make other
than that it's probably should just be
used as you know bragging rights for
players amongst themselves you know what
I mean
um I saw I talked to be shot this year
after we played the Clippers and he was
joking you know with me and Norm oh
y'all y'all only got one you know what I
mean like right you know what I mean
something like that like that was a cool
funny little jab that was like all right
I get that part of it but like for fans
or people on TV or whatever to be trying
to tear a guy you know a superstar down
for not when it ring I think it's a
little crazy no for sure did winning
that ring in that moment that you won
the championship did it feel exactly how
you thought it would feel did it live up
to it did it not yeah it exceeded all
expectations it really did because you
think about the moment you think about
some of the plays that you want to make
you think about being a guy you think
about obviously you see you only know
what you see
um because most guys don't go to the
finals if they're not in it right but
you think about the confetti you think
about celebrating holding the trophy up
in the champagne and that's really about
it you know what I mean but it's like so
many other little moments in there like
just on the phone my mom crying you know
what I mean she crying as soon as I call
her
um the parade like and just being a big
part of that moment for that last game
was was a special you know for me and my
career I just try to build on that since
then no I love that it certainly was a
really great moment
um weird question but when did
basketball start feeling like a job to
you when did that shift happen
um
I would say
probably the last couple years last two
or three years
um
even my first couple years you know I
was just so hungry and just so ready to
make a statement and make my name and
get a real contract you know I mean that
I would just focused on every single day
I was still having fun I think you know
as your role grows and expectation grows
and money grows like
your plate gets a little bit bigger of
things that you're required to do or ask
to do so there's some days when you know
you feel like it's a job but I think
having uh love and passion for the game
is what eliminates all of that so just
get lost in the work and get lost in the
craft and just enjoy playing basketball
but there's so much other things that
come with it now
um it's turned into like a 24-hour news
cycle three you know 365 a year so it's
a little
annoying in that regard sometimes but
you know just keep a good perspective
and just understand how blessed I am to
be in this position I think that always
will balance it back up yeah in the Last
Dance documentary when Scottie Pippen
was talking he was like I I would do the
basketball for free yeah they pay you
for the yeah and I feel like
yeah and I feel like that's kind of what
most NBA players feel like it's that
you're having to deal with all of that
ancillary stuff yeah it comes with I
think as a as the years go by and like I
said before the game grows like it's
just so much other multimedia
entertainment values stuff that comes
with it
um you know I have a young family to
travel you know being a ways all of that
stuff piles into it but like this is all
I ever really wanted to do my whole life
you know and I'm it's allowed me the
game has allowed me to be in this
position and see other things to even
have a chance to know that I want to do
something else you know what I mean and
like I could never forget that so I'll
just try to be good to the game itself
and always you know pay that back with
how I approach every day yeah I mean
speaking of so I had Tyrese Halliburton
on the show and he tells me a story
about his rookie year game's over you
all beat them and he said that you came
up to him and you were like you know I
see something in you you know like right
now you're coming off the bench what do
you do to be a sixth man then what do
you do to be a starter then what do you
do to be an All-Star do you remember
this moment that you had with Tyrese
yeah I did not remember until he said it
when I seen him when I seen him uh when
I saw the interview I remembered it but
I never thought nothing of it you know
what I mean because I do that I do that
to guys who probably never turn out to
be him you know what I mean but there's
a lot of guys in this league with Talent
that's just waiting on the right
opportunity in the right moment so I
remember that after he said it yeah what
prompted you to do that with Tyrese I
think it was uh
obviously I've seen him in Iowa State
um I follow basketball so you know I I
was watching them and we were getting
ready to play them and he had been
playing really well he was shooting like
40 from three at the time and he was
coming off the bench and every time he
checked in they were going these runs
like I'm doing my homework right we're
getting ready to play them and then the
coaches come with the scouting report
and they're like man this kid he's funky
he's got a little weird shot it takes
the time to get it up but don't leave
him open he can shoot like don't don't
fall asleep don't sleep on this kid he
played well against us again and um it
was just one of those things where it
was like I could see
that it was something there but I could
also see him trying to figure it out and
being coming off the bench even though
he probably should have a ball in his
hands and the team wasn't that great at
the time so it was like he was playing
behind Fox and
um I just saw I had been in that
position where I felt like I could do
more felt like you know I knew what I
could do I was just waiting on my moment
and I just wanted to let him know that
because some guys will get lost and uh
the game of like waiting your turn you
can get lost in that you know if there's
not a real reason why you're not getting
your opportunity you just gotta wait
most guys will kind of like check out
yeah you know what I mean getting ahead
about it because you check you're
getting paid regardless you come to work
the same no matter what and then
sometimes it's like there's really no
reason why you're not playing you just
gotta wait your turn yeah you know it's
just a pecking order and how things go
you know I love when he told me that
story because to him it clearly meant so
much it's a thing that he cherished the
thing that he still thinks about do you
were like I remember doing it but I
didn't remember until it happened so it
was this small moment for you that was
huge for him did you have that moment
who did that for you absolutely it was a
lot of guys
um one that I really remember and I
think we talked about her before was JJ
was JJ Redick and um
somehow I ended up being the guy that
they wanted me to guard JJ chase them
around and stuff like that so like
literally he was checking in and I was
checking in and we were standing there
at the at the scores table and he just
tapped me he's like yo man like you're
one of my favorite players to watch in
the league like and I'm you know I'm
still coming off the bench I'm playing
like 15 18 minutes a game I know I'm
nice but like yeah I'm not doing nothing
crazy
and in my head I'm just like damn this
JJ Redick you know like I watched him at
Duke you know like I got a ton of
respect for him
um and then it was like a split second I
was like all right he just trying to
throw you off you know I mean he's
trying to throw you up so so you know
what I mean we go down and as soon as we
check in I'm guarding them he throw
throw a little elbow right in my chest
boom run off the screen I'm like all
right yeah yeah that's a veteran that's
a vet right that's an old vet move
trying to gasp me yeah but then we we
talked a little bit after the game
um there was a lot of guys and then me
and Kyle we would just go down the list
of like game plans and Skyrim Forces
teams and be like all right you better
than him you better than him you're
better than him and like you know before
I knew it there wasn't many other point
guards or backups at the time that
um I thought were better than me so that
was like my marker to keep going and
keep working until I got my opportunity
what kind of mental fortitude does it
take to know you're nice but also know
that like everybody else isn't seeing it
it takes a lot you got to be mentally
strong but again I think you just gotta
know the situation that you're in and be
realistic about that first so like me
from day one I always challenge Kyle
like I was
just as good as him now the first couple
weeks of the season was very humbling
because I was like all right I can't do
what he doing like I couldn't do it you
know what I mean so what do I do instead
of me sitting there mad that I'm not
playing I'm gonna try to learn as much
from him as possible knowing that
there's a gap there you know what I'm
saying a seven eight year Gap like when
he's done here then I'll still be here
you know what I mean so I was trying to
learn as much from him as possible so
much so that we got super close and
ended up playing together
right which was even better because we
we helped each other so much so that's
just how I approached it at the time and
um I've never played for a bad coach
and I've never had a issue with any of
my coaches so that's something that I've
been blessed to be able to say and if
there's any ever
um
miscommunication or anything like I
always just try to be upfront about it
and like why am I not playing or what do
I need to do what do you give me
something so my first couple years I
would just ask the assistants like what
do I need to work on all right you need
to speed up your release you need to
pick up full court every time you check
into the game
um Rex kalamian
um he told me he told all the young guys
at the time like when we call your name
you know to come in the game you need to
run to the school yeah be ready don't
walk don't be down there hide don't sit
all the way at the end in the tunnel
like sit next to the coaches so I just
try to take as many of those gems as I
could and
um it helped me a lot yeah I mean
obviously we all know bet on yourself
that is your motto your Mantra but it
feels like at every step of your career
you have been trying or having to prove
who you are to other people yeah do you
still feel like you're trying to prove
who you are to others no I I never
really looked at it like that I and and
the bet on yourself thing became a big
thing but it's like that's really who I
am like I really live like that like
it's not just a saying it's like the way
I live is my personality is you know my
character so I always just looked at
like proving myself right proving my
loved ones right I never really worried
about like trying to convince somebody
they'll catch on eventually for me it's
like proven to myself that I can do it
you know what I mean like I know how I
feel about myself and until I go out
there and prove it it's not valid so
every step of the way is always going to
be doubters for me like I just know that
that's how my whole life has been that's
not going to change and
um it's great it's a great position to
be in you know I never have to worry
about getting too big-headed you know
what I mean because I always got to
overcome some type of challenge or
obstacle or whatever critic whatever it
is uh it just keeps me focused and you
know keeps me sharp so if you look at
your journey in basketball
what moment would you double down on and
say this moment fueled me to get where
I'm at
um
it's crazy I had to go all the way back
to
high school maybe
yeah probably high school and I was um
maybe 10th 10th or 11th grade
somewhere in there and there was a
there was like this message board Forum
before all of this stuff came out it was
this message board form that was talking
about some of the state recruits and
there was like this one comment that my
brother had showed me and it was just
talking about like Fred would never play
in college he'll never play D1 like he's
not he's not good enough he's going to
be a junior college D3 player or
something like that right and here I am
thinking like man I'm about to go to
Kentucky like that's just how I felt at
the time you know what I mean but it was
like one thing that was like all right I
can't I can't let that dude be right
I can't let that dude and of course
along the way there's so many other
things but like that's one thing that
sticks out to me I'm still trying to
find it because I would like frame that
comment yeah
um but yeah stuff like that is is just
you know you just add it to the list why
do you think that one specifically you
think it was just the first time that
you really blatantly saw someone talking
about you in that way yeah and it was
the first time that I saw somebody be so
drastically far away from how I felt
about myself because you can never
really control how people see you or
perceive you or view you but like I knew
how I felt about myself I'm going D1 I'm
going to the biggest best school and I'm
going first year one and done to the
league lottery pick like this is what I
thought about myself you know
um and then here's this person that took
the time to type this up on a computer
or something with such conviction about
a 14 15 year old kid so I was like okay
you know I'm gonna do everything in my
power to make sure that you know that
that's not true we gotta find homie and
see look yeah I gotta look at her I
gotta find it somewhere it's somewhere
I'm gonna find it yeah was there ever a
moment that you almost succumbed to that
thinking
um
I had a couple of real low moments I
think
um my first day of college practice I
called my mom I wanted to quit
I was so tired and so sick like I caught
like the flu for 24 hours like coach ran
Us in the dirt it was probably the
hardest thing I ever done to this day my
first preseason practice at Wichita
State as a freshman College freshman I
went back to my dorm room
called my mom I'm like Mom I don't know
if this for me I don't know if I could
do this and she was laughing and you
know she was just like man you'll get
through it you know take a nap or
whatever call me when you get up so I
went to sleep I woke up I was fine
obviously but I was gonna say were you
actually closed or was it just the
moment physically sick like I had never
been physically sick from playing
basketball and I was just like it was
day one and we had like 30 days of that
before the first preseason game so in my
head I'm like I can't do this again yeah
God because I got there and I'm a you
know I'm a try hard so like I'm going
down my heart I'm trying to be first in
Sprints all the Vets all the seniors
they faking injuries so they don't have
to like run the Sprints faking
hamstrings stuff like that but uh I
didn't know no better at the time so I'm
doing everything all out
um but I was fine the next day and then
draft night you know that was a that was
a moment it wasn't like I was gonna quit
but it was definitely a moment where I
was just like all right I gotta I gotta
get back in my bag and figure out how
man you know my what's my next move yeah
okay well now you're in the league
you've lived that dream
obviously a lot of discourse happening
in the NBA right now about referees
oh um you might know a little something
about that yeah
broad question
um what do you want to see from referees
I asked Spencer generated the same
question just tell me what you want to
see from referees um I think for me the
really the only thing I want as somebody
who is you know one of the leaders on my
team somebody who communicates with the
officials like throughout the game
um I would just like to see more uh of a
better relationship between the players
and the officials you know and
um
they got an impossible job you know for
sure
um especially with social media and like
there's people on Twitter breaking down
every call and they posting it like the
refs are going through what some of the
players have been going through for the
longest now where you are getting
publicly ridiculed and you are getting
you got to read through comments about
how bad you were and you know so they're
adjusting in real time but I think just
the like the discourse and the
communication between
the players and the refs has gone a
little sideways with the new rules of
like what's a technical file and what's
not so let's just get back to like
unsportsmanlike conduct right
cussing and fussing or you know you you
tripping right we know how to get
attacked like I've been in League long I
know how to earn a tech right for like
slapping the hands you know the rules I
think it just got to be better
what's the word I don't know
jurisdiction or you know better uh
a better feel for the actual game in the
moment and not like all right this is
the rule and this is how I'm gonna call
it yeah because just because it's the
rule don't make it right you know what I
mean and I think that unless it's some
long-term play I don't fully understand
yet I just don't see how that benefits
our game you know I think letting the
players have emotion and being able to
react and
again
I'm gonna get eight to ten texts on the
year just because I play with fire and
you know I understand that part but
some of them are like it's getting it's
going a little too far on the other side
right
the game we got a competition committee
they are going to handle whatever comes
within the cause and the changes we make
to the rules and things like that but
just the communication would be my
biggest thing in all of the older
veteran referees are really good at it
they know how to listen they know how to
let you they've been here they'll give
you a tech if you're tripping and
they'll walk away you know what I mean
they know how to do it it's some of the
the younger ones that are still learning
and trying to find themselves that's
like they're using the tech as like a
weapon like a defense you know what I
mean like I have this and I can give it
to you it's like an authority thing and
it's just I don't believe the game
should be like that not at this level
yeah now I mean I know you apologize for
the talk that you had in the press
conference to um Ben Taylor
but were you happy that you were able to
speak your mind yeah I mean look and I
said it then like I'm human you know I'm
pretty
um measured and well reserved most of
the time I I don't speak my mind all the
time so that was something that just
came out it just happened you know I was
frustrated we had a couple bad nights in
a row and um
I I don't really regret it you know
maybe not saying his name so it wasn't
so much attention on him but you know
obviously he was on my mind at the time
so uh I don't have an issue with Ben you
know have you been able to speak we
talked when the last time we played like
it'll be regular you know what I mean I
think I made my point and I think that
um
we saw the reception around the league
like I wasn't only speaking for myself I
watched multiple games every night you
know what I mean so I know what I'm
talking about
um again I paid the fine I did you know
I did the crime I did the time
so every ref that I've been seeing you
know from then on I've been letting them
know like hey I made my point I'm done
with it I don't want no more smoke I
don't want no I'm good like I'm sorry I
had to do it I had to get that out and
you know let's move on so it wasn't
really that like a big of a thing for me
but in that moment you know I had to
speak my mind yeah and also honestly it
probably did just like feel goodness
okay this is how I feel I'm gonna be
respectful I'm gonna say sorry we'll
move on from it but
you want to see some sort of change you
know and the only way to do that is to
talk about it yeah and I think just for
me like I'm not gonna not say something
when I think is wrong and I just thought
that the way that that situation had
been going on for me personally and for
our team and the things that I've been
watching I do think is wrong yeah
I'm not saying I'm perfect and I make a
ton of mistakes obviously and I don't
usually even appeal my texts or argue
most of my texts because I know what I'm
doing before I do it but some of those
ones was just like all right bro what
are we doing yeah yeah like I can't
stand for this yeah like come on man I
mean it was it's a good clip yeah yeah
it's very good clip but I love how okay
I'm a little embarrassed about it now
because I'm just looking like damn like
I didn't have to do all of that but I
was just in the moment I didn't really
ask me a question about it I just kind
of
I felt like I didn't have nothing else
to to do like when I was talking to him
I couldn't get through to him so I'm
just like all right yeah like Mike's in
front of my my face now like my name is
carries a lot of weight and my word
carries weight you know what I mean so
that's something I'm learning to deal
with too yeah well because I was gonna
say you could argue that the fact that
you don't do things like this all the
time
it carries more of that weight because
like okay if Fred is deciding to speak
about this he feels it and I think
that's what people felt around the
league yeah and I and I think also there
is a lot of guys just like me even more
respectable than me that feel the exact
same way it's just that when you get up
to the microphone you just always think
like all right is this worse if is it
worth 30 000 is it worth 50 000 is it
worth fifteen thousand I don't want to
give these people my money so you
usually just don't say nothing but I
mean in that moment I just was like I
don't care what is you know I mean I
don't care what the fines gonna be I got
to get this off and
um that was really it yeah no like I
said I have it say it I'm like I might I
might just need to do a little some
memes off that
um I want to talk to CBA a little bit
obviously these still have to be
ratified by players team Governors it's
all tentative
um there have just been reports that
have come up about it I'm gonna say one
of the things you do with thumbs up or
thumbs down and how you feel about it
okay and you tell me why
mandatory 65 games played to be eligible
for postseason Awards
oh my no I didn't I didn't think that
was that crazy like that's fair you know
I mean it sucks for guys that's going to
be injured you know some of the best
players in the league that may have
missed time but like 65 is a fair number
I think you know to be eligible it'll be
interesting to see how that you know
affects the all NBA stuff yeah which is
the only one that I'm a little torn
about like MVP and some of the other
ones but like all NBA if you're the best
15 for 64 games like you know I mean
that that would be tough but uh yeah
they got it they have to try to show
that they're doing something so I get
that one see because that's the only
thing that's going to happen it's like
there's going to be a guy that played
63. he's gonna say so I don't get this
because I play 63 games there's never
going to be a number that appeases all
people right and even when you look it's
like 65 games when you look at some of
the stars in the league a lot of them
haven't reached that due to injuries and
stuff so there's never going to be
enough but I understand it for those
like those big rewards like MVP I mean I
get it why they're trying to do it they
want the best players to play more games
I just don't know if you can reel that
back in at this point yeah you know what
I mean and also what's going to happen
when somebody has a sprained ankle and
they suit up to play for 30 seconds and
they sell about to make sure that
they're eligible like you know that's
something that we may see as well so I
don't know but again I'm not in the
office to
you know make these rules or changes so
I'm not going to criticize them but yeah
I didn't mind that one okay the End
season tournament thumbs up thumbs down
thumbs down only because like I said
before like I don't think the game needs
all of this new stuff that we're doing
but like I told you off air in 20 years
We're Not Gonna recognize the game
anyway yeah you know what I mean the
same way the guys from the 80s and 90s
probably don't recognize what they're
watching now
um anytime a hardware classes come on
and I'm watching 10 players inside the
paint in the restricted areas nobody
standing behind the three-point line you
know it's gonna look like that probably
to us when we're done so just being in
the middle of some of the changes you
know again try to be open-minded about
it it'd probably be it's probably gonna
be crazy though like yeah after a couple
years ago by yeah
it should be some good Hoops you know in
the early part of the season so I'm not
mad at that but I would say I wouldn't
have like made that up I wouldn't have
voted for that yeah I don't know if I
ever thought in my head oh like one day
when I watched NBA there will be an
in-season tournament where like you win
500 000 if you win it all you know like
I just that's not a thing that you think
about happening but no I think the
playing tournament's very exciting so
I'm sure the End season tournament will
be um same thing I mean the game is
changing drastically so just try to be
open-minded about it okay weed removed
from the drug testing program
oh thumbs up I think that was I mean
pretty much already in place Yeah
official
um since covet
um yeah I think you know
anything with balance and responsibility
makes sense and I don't think you can
justify alcohol without you know I mean
marijuana so uh I'm not mad at that one
either okay last CBA one uh one and done
rules stays the same that one I was
surprised about I don't know how I feel
about that yet but um I thought that one
was gonna change they have been talking
about trying to get that one changed for
a while but um they didn't get it done
on this one
um again maybe with the nil changing in
the business model changing a little bit
bottom a little more time
it really only sucks for the guys that's
ready to go right away yeah like and
that's not that many people you know you
look at a guy maybe like Paulo or
um scoot or you know even um
Victor probably you know I mean like
those type of guys but they don't come
around that often right
uh I get it but
I don't know
four and a half years at College They
Don't Really apply to me but it was a
heck of a time especially in March
um I do want to talk about the Raptors
season a little bit I know Nick nurse
described this as a difficult season for
him what has this season been for you
just up and down it's just been a lot of
everything it's been really good it's
been bad at times it's been fun it's
been depressing I think we've we've seen
it all we've had injuries we played well
we played bad
um we've had a lot of different little
seasons in one so I would just say
roller coaster up and down
um for some of our group that's been
together that's been around since the
championship and before
um it's all new Charter you know
unchartered territory but we're used to
being at the top and now we're a little
bit you know lower than that and we're
adjusting to it so uh yeah it's been
it's been a weird year for sure but
again just trying to stay focused and
finish up on a good note
[Music]
you know looking some of your stats some
of the games you've played in
do you feel like just
historically you struggle against the
Sixers
um I have had struggles against the
sixes for sure
um especially in the playoffs which
which I can never get that back so that
will always be there
um the championship year
I can never get that impression back
um but there's also been games where
I've scored 30 and 20 you know and beat
them and play well too during the
regular season so I've had some success
and I've had some struggles and um I
think uh since Doc's been there they
definitely guard me differently and
showed me a lot of attention with this
team and
um I got off to a decent start in the
playoffs last year before I got hurt I
didn't shoot it well after the first
couple games but
um yeah for sure they definitely um they
definitely guard me and show me a lot of
attention yeah because I was going to
say what do you think you attribute that
to the times that you have struggled I
know it has to be in every outing well
the first time in the playoffs was just
more so me
in the road that I was in against that
matchup it just wasn't a good matchup
for me at the time you know what I mean
where my game was and I was really just
running around playing defense and
trying to get some catching shoots and I
you know you miss a couple of those now
you not making any and
um it just wasn't my time at that time
and then you know fast forward again
like I'm one of the main focal points of
the team so
um to me anytime I get draw attention
double teams or whatever you know I
think I've done my job but I got to find
a way to be more effective when I'm
being keyed in on for sure
about the specifics of your contract
situation I know you said that you don't
want to talk about that um you said I
think in the beginning of the season
but when you think about rumors when you
see trade rumors when you see your name
in the news is it just weird for you to
think about a time not being a raptor
being that it's been your whole career
in Toronto yeah for sure and it's not
really something I ever thought about
you know what I mean like even within
all the rumors because I have such a
great relationship with management and
ownership like it's really a family
thing so even when all the outside noise
was going on there really was no talk
behind the scenes at least with me and
them of like hey we might move you we
might you know like teams were calling
of course like there's a lot of teams
that could use me that feel like you
know I would take them over to hump to
win a championship especially this year
um but yeah it's been like I said this
is my first time being my name in the
news this much consistently and it was
about a month straight of like every day
a new rumor yeah they're like I turned
on this or I'm going here or I'm going
there and um
yeah I've just been so locked in and
like I just love hard and I'm just
committed to this group and you know
what I what we built here
um that yeah I never really thought
about being nowhere else and that's a
you know time for the summer time to let
the business be business but um right
now I think just locked in on this
season with this team good and I mean I
think that's important you know you
saying that you have that trust in that
relationship with the management because
even when you know you see the stories
that Jalen Brown did the interview is
saying you know he called up management
and said okay what's going on am I being
traded what are you guys thinking about
and I don't know if that type of
relationship exists in every
organization so for you to feel like
that you have that I'm sure is a big
plus yeah no I'm I'm very grateful for
my situation and you know this this
franchise gave me a chance you know what
I mean like I'm in the NBA because they
believed in me you know what I mean and
that's something that I don't take for
granted or don't take lightly and also I
just love Messiah I got a great
relationship with Bobby you know what I
mean like if I got an issue or something
I'm just going to text him or call him
or when I see him I'm gonna ask him like
what's up you know what I mean and vice
versa and he comes straight to me with
anything that he has to do like I don't
really play too much you know media
games or in between games where I'm
trying to manipulate things like that
I'm more of a direct person so yeah
that's what allowed me to just stay sane
but like definitely a couple weeks where
I got to stay off Twitter you know what
I mean like you got to be able to manage
that you know so I definitely like have
a off and on again thing with Twitter
and you know it's just balancing that
out as best I can I think we all do yeah
yeah but I did what you did was very
very smart and very real but you just
put out this is what I'm thinking I
don't want to talk about it until the
time comes because it you would be asked
about it yeah like every other week um
like what's the update on this so I
thought I thought that you handled it
yeah and the timing of that was just
unfortunate because it was just people
who really didn't have a full grasp of
the situation and there was already so
many other rumors going on that's like
all right we're not going to add my
contract into this part of the thing
like I turned down this so now I'm on a
trade block and X Y and Z like people
trying to put all these different
theories together so it's just you know
I'ma always speak my piece and dress
things if I have to yeah absolutely
um okay so last little section for you
so I got very happy when I first met
Fred because Fred is from Rockford
Illinois I went to University of
Illinois and I was like do I know any of
your friends I didn't
but tell the people tell me some of the
great Parts about growing up in Rockford
and tell me some of the harder Parts
I think the great Parts is just having
um
a strong close community of growing up
where everybody knows everybody family
is huge it's really like one of those
places that just roughens you up
toughens you up and makes you um you
know unflappable unbreakable if you can
make it there you can make it anywhere
like it's one of those type of places
and I owe so much of who I am and my
character and just the morals and
principles that I stand on to
to Rockford and um just trying to be a
solid individual you know what I mean
like we're very judgmental place like we
got a real small core set of beliefs so
we look at some people like weirdos it's
just it just is what it is but um and
then the tough part is you know is all
the other stuff like the crime and you
know the lack of opportunity and
um the economic you know situation there
but
I never really focus on that part too
much because number one
I was doing the best out of all of my
friends so like
I never wanted to make it seem like oh I
had it so rough and tough growing up
because I know what my brothers and my
friends and people that I love went
through that was a thousand times worse
than what I went through
um and two like I'm actively trying to
change it and I actually have been
trying to change it since I went away to
college to make a change in my community
um but also I don't think you can do
that while
trying to highlight all the bad stuff
you know so I just always try to spend a
positive with it because we are making a
big change in the city and um you know
we will continue to do that you know
what I think about is so you are one of
my favorites you always one of my
favorites but one of the things that
really solidified it for me was in the
bubble when everyone was talking about
social justice and you know all the
police brutality was happening in that
moment I asked you a question and you
were so real in your answer about how it
has affected your life and how you take
in violence and seeing things like this
and it was such an honest moment and one
thing that you said in it is there are
times that you feel guilty what did you
mean by that
um I think like like I said going back
to my previous Point
um I had
so obviously my father was killed when I
was five right my mom did what she had
to do live with my grandparents back and
forth they lived across the street they
raised us up until about nine or ten
moved in with my stepdad who is my dad
um he raised us so essentially I had two
parents you know what I mean and between
the two he was a full-time police
officer my mom had a decent job like we
had everything we needed you know what I
mean like yeah the light bill may get
cut off or they may file bankruptcy or
whatever like but we have money to play
with you know what I mean
um we still did food stamps and all that
like we still did all of that stuff but
like compared to my friends like when I
go to my basketball game my parents was
in the crowd I had basketball sneakers
to go to a tournament I have money to my
mom sent me to live with Antonio Davis
for a summer in sixth grade to play with
him like you know I mean I had
opportunities and my parents really
sacrificed a lot for me to have these
opportunities
and the reason why I say that is because
I've seen the flip side of that you know
with the same team the same kid in the
same situation the same school even the
same neighborhood you know their mom
might not have been able to go to the
game because she was working
so I never wanted to make it seem like I
was just oh the sob story and made it
from crumbs to Greatness you know what I
mean because I know the infrastructure
that I have played a huge part and I owe
that to my parents and my family for
sure and it just shaped me to be who I
am but just understanding that not
everybody has the same equal opportunity
yeah and while I may have had it bad to
some people like I didn't know that
until I went to college and I saw that
you could leave your doors unlocked then
you can drive a Mercedes and you can
live in a million dollar home and you
can have a chef and you can fly a
private jet like I didn't even know
these things existed until I was you
know 18 19 years old and then I started
thinking like damn we was okay we was
eating ribs for breakfast and
Thanksgiving dinner two three weeks like
okay that's not normal you know what I
mean yeah it took me to leave my
environment to know that that wasn't
normal but I was never like
running around like I was messed up when
I was in Rockford I was decent yeah
because your environment around you
right
so as a dad
how do you make sure your children have
that perspective of okay we live like
this yeah there are people who don't and
I also was one of those people that did
it you know yeah they won't
they won't they won't they won't at all
but again that's it's an everyday
challenge for me yeah
um so this summer my daughter's five now
so I'm starting to work on her a little
bit because I understand so we're gonna
go give away some of her toys and things
like that and go feed and do some work
in the community just so she could see
the other side of it
um and then you know I got to make a
decision on schooling and where I want
them to go to school and what their
social environment is going to be like
that's a lot of responsibility to try to
shape you know little humans but um they
will never have what I got and where I
got it from you know what I mean which
is the reason why I work so hard is so
they don't have to go through that yeah
but now it's up to them to be greater
and better than me the same way that my
parents sacrificed for me to be farther
ahead than them you know what I mean so
they just got to give me a little return
on my investment when they get older and
you know we're going to be good
absolutely I love that okay well as our
one of our favorite undrafted players
they want me to ask you your top three
undrafted players I feel like I know one
or at least I should know who number one
is uh I I think Ben Wallace always comes
to mind for sure he's like amazing
um
John Starks
and uh
who's the third
the dinosaur yes because like undrafted
to 20-year career staple
um impeccable name respect around the
world I got to put him on the list I
like UD a lot yeah and I would say like
honorable mention Bruce Bowen Bruiser
Udonis I feel like and that's in that
slot I think UD is a little closer to
like how I came up than Bruce but yeah I
like him I mean anybody undrafted I got
a soft spot for for sure why do you
think players fall through the cracks
um timing opportunity uh
information like I didn't know that the
NBA wants you to shoot and score like
first I didn't know that you know I mean
it took me my first year to be like we
don't we don't want you to be a floor
manager like we don't we don't need that
you know we need you to shoot and score
and be a threat I'm like okay but then
College if I shot some of the shots I
shoot now like I was getting cussed out
the next day like it was being on film
you know what I mean like I didn't we
got in trouble for shooting floaters
right we got in trouble for shooting
transition threes sometimes if they
didn't go in I didn't know no better so
I think for me that's what happened I
think people make mistakes like
people in these front offices they they
are smart people they don't know
everything and they they make mistakes
and they're wrong just as much as
they're right and so you get guys that
fall through the cracks
um that don't quit that don't give up
you know I'm looking at Austin Reeves
and Jose Alvarado and Alice Caruso like
real deal players you know what I mean
but the draft is for a talent and upside
there really is something too like you
and those players you named y'all just
play with a different type of grit and
intensity you got to be a dog because
nobody don't believe in you anyway so
you got to be a super dog you know what
I mean because you got to prove it and
like now everybody's an underdog like
the number one pick is an underdog
because when he goes on his Instagram
he's going to see a thousand DM tell him
he sucks and he won't make it he's going
to be a bus
but some of us have to prove it like to
the coach to the management to the Scout
to everybody you know what I mean and I
think that's just a different level of
dog that you got to be yeah and
absolutely shows okay last one for you
what if you weren't an NBA player what
would you be doing
I have no idea I never even thought that
far I ain't gonna lie I never even
thought that far like I was just
basketball basketball I like football I
stopped playing football
you like music I like music but I don't
have no music or Talent like I can't
sing or nothing so without produce or be
a manager or something I don't know
wherever college would have took me
because I was going to go to college
regardless yeah so wherever that would
have took me but yeah I didn't really
have interest in nothing else what'd you
major in sociology
okay so I went to school I did all my
classes sociology was the only class I
like that ended up being my major I
loved it yeah that was it but I don't
know what I'll be doing if I wasn't
playing basketball no I know now but I
don't know what I've done back then yeah
something with people for sure yeah yeah
yeah for sure we'll explore whatever
that is yeah no doubt I gotta think
about it yes well Fred thank you so much
for your time I'm so happy that we got
to finally do this although I'm sad you
know Toronto is one of my favorite
cities so I wish we were out there in
Toronto doing it but I'm happy that I
was able to make it work in Charlotte
and I got to see a concert it was a work
trip I was into it yeah
you're welcome yes I appreciate you
friends thanks so much
[Music]
foreign